hi i'm jason earls i'm joshua bassett
and i'm matt gornett and this is wired
autocomplete interview
you ready i'm ready
to go let's go
ready what are joshua bassett fans
called oh my gosh this is controversial
what do they call themselves yeah that's
that's what i don't know i truly don't
don't know it changes all the time next
what is joshua famous for hell if i know
i would probably say high school musical
and i'd like to think the music i think
you're famous for your curly hair ah
shucks
what is joshua bassett vocal range dude
it changes all the time i mean when
puberty had it was devastating i used to
be oh wait i should find this when i was
10 i i put together this thing of me
singing like literally as high as i
possibly could because for whatever
reason i wanted to do this collaboration
of all these different songs but really
i used to think when i was little and
this is what happens when you're in
musical theater as a guy is the higher
you can sing the better you are which is
not the case but i just used to make as
high as i possibly could because i
thought that was what would make uh me
impressive
i got it
[Music]
and that
needs some new eardrums what instruments
did joshua basket play piano drums
ukulele bass guitar a little bit of
saxophone i can only play flyme to the
moon so in short all of them almost just
about
wow what does joshua bassett improvise
no and in the end of season one after we
did a handful of takes tim fetterly the
showrunner pulled me aside and he's like
okay we have it when you get to this
line say whatever the hell you want and
then whenever you're done get back on
script and i was mortified i was like
what am i going to say i have no idea
what to say i ended up going on this
whole rant and i'm pretty sure they kept
i think they used most of me yeah it's
crazy so and what's crazy is i still see
people reciting the entire monologue
word for word like in front of the east
high school and whatnot but yeah well
that was great
thanks top to bottom baby you ready
matt cornett van
have you ever read any of them you know
i don't i don't think i actually have
mainly because i'm scared too but no
i've seen like instagram uh instagram
or whatever yeah and like like little
edits that people make of of you and i
it's cute matt cornett workout workout
routine when we're filming josh and i
like to go to the gym together and try
to like out work out each other it's
kind of good because then i see him
making progress and i'm like oh i need
to do some things that like really add
some heavy heavy weight so that i can
like look better than josh of course
it's with love though it's with yeah i
know it's with plenty of love matt
cornett dog oh speaking of we were just
talking about coda we were i do have a
dog she's actually probably here with us
now in my jacket her fur goes everywhere
i go her name is coda kota and she's a
siberian husky and she's the sweetest
cutest thing on planet earth and i love
her so much and she's like my little
baby and you can find her on my
instagram somewhere give a quick photo i
do take as much time as i did please i
promise this will be working guys
totally
thank you oh my god isn't this adorable
look
all right matt cornett
look alike i feel like a lot of people
say harry styles which i don't see but
you've told me harry styles before in
the eyes i see a little bit like
depending on how moppy your hair is
let's be clear harry styles looks like
you matt cornette flip flops i would
love to know why people are looking up
well matt couldn't have flip-flops why i
own one pair of flip-flops that only get
worn when i go to the beach i'm not
really a flip-flop guy
okay oh
ready let's do it what
happened to jason
i don't even think jason i don't know
i'm telling you the last 20 years have
been a blur
i like god i grew up and then i went to
college and then i ended up in l.a and
then like a bunch of [ __ ] happened i
was on hannah montana and that was weird
i did kick it and i kind of like
hung out and played video games for a
couple of years and then i started doing
high school musicals
you know what endlessly good things i
have a wonderful wife i have lots of
great friends i work on very cool shows
so like good stuff happened to
this guy all right
are john cena and jason earls the same
age
and the answer to this question is no
john cena is actually three days older
than i am what whoa and what'll really
blow your mind is if you go back and
watch hannah montana there's an episode
that john cena's in it's like where i'm
like i don't want to read for school or
whatever so he pops into my imagination
he's like reading is good and like all
that and he literally picks me up spins
me over his head throws me over a couch
it's the best episode ever and if you
look at john cena and me side by side
you go
they're not even the same species how
old was jason earls in american pie i
did american pie band camp right before
we did the pilot for hannah montana so i
probably would have been in my mid-20s
and you think i look young the first
year of hannah i look even younger in
american pie i probably look like i'm 15
maybe in that movie wow was jason earls
in glee
i was not in glee who do they think is
you liam michelle
that makes the most sense jeremy renner
that one i guess oh jeremy renner i
confuse them all the time yes i was at a
toys r us and a kid came up and was like
oh my god are you and i was i thought
they were talking about hannah montana
and i was like yeah and they're like oh
my god hawkeye i loved you and
he thought i was jeremy renner and i was
like
thank you it was such a fun movie to do
and i signed no you did not i 100 did
i was not gonna ruin that kid's
experience with jeremy renner so jeremy
you're welcome oh
there you go
i almost murdered someone with that hsmt
mts
recap
basically
you're following the theater kids at
east high and we live in a world where
the east high is where they filmed the
high school musical movies so then we
kind of freak out that our our school is
famous from being in movies and the
second season what should we do beauty
and the beast
and then season three is at summer camp
and we're doing frozen which is
hilarious it's just mtm sm
versus hsm but i think what's cool about
our show is that it's completely
different like it really is self-aware
we are not trying to be any sort of
sequel or anything like it's its own
universe so you know i can only hope
that there's something in each of them
that people can walk away with but i
think they're incomparable really
they're just completely different i also
really appreciate how because we're in a
television show and we have more time we
can go more into different story lines
that show the humanity in a lot of
characters and we can deal with a
handful of different issues anything
from anxiety to sexuality to everything
in between you know it doesn't have to
fit in 90 minutes we can sort of expand
on these characters and i think it's
cool to to talk about more real and
current issues doing husk musical in
2022. who wrote hsmt mts songs
lots of people wrote it to some tmts
songs olivia rodrigo and i have written
a handful of songs for the show dara
renee wrote a song that might be a
secret we have a handful of other
songwriters it's actually cool each song
is written pretty much by a different
person and you get a good variety from
that but i was fortunate enough to write
another song for season three called
finally free and it's out now with the
the first episode of this season so very
excited about that who
are the characters in hsn tmts there's a
lot there's a lot of great ones i hate
too many hit us with the regulars go
ricky nini gina ej carlos seb courtney
courtney
ashley ashlynn big red we got miss jen
we got mr mazar uh lily we have antoine
howie
yeah
this season though we have a lot of new
characters we have jojo siwa who's uh
joining the cast corbin blue like we
said is joining the cast meg donnelly is
joining the cast adrian lyles jesse
tyler ferguson
we have a lot of awesome new characters
and really i think the world is just
going to fall in love with each and
every one of them who choreographer hsn
tmts zach woodley who choreographically
uh is a choreographer and he is the
funniest guy oh my gosh he is just a
hoot and so
wonderful to work with and he's
brilliant like he really has the vision
and it's so wonderful to be able to
trust someone like him to like just help
us with everything and i will say going
into the show i had no dance experience
like literally zero to the point to
where we had to do what they called a
move-in groove session just so they
could see if we could actually move our
bodies and somehow
by the grace of god zach woodley uh was
able to to make us well i'll stand up
for myself president speak for myself
presentable
is hsm tmts based on a true story
all of it's real i will say though like
talking to tim federly who created it
i'm pretty sure each character is
inspired by a real person and also this
show has this really uncanny ability to
like
put something in the show that was
written months before
that parallel something that is exactly
happening in someone's life when we
shoot it totally it's a very very
bizarre almost supernatural thing that
happens where's
a lot three just hit the face
oh my why does joshua bassett oh that's
scary oh my gosh why does joshua bastard
have a teddy bear it's actually a funny
story so i was at um this fair thing i
don't even know what arizona maybe and
me and my friends were being followed by
a swarm of tween girls and we were like
we need to hide so we ran into
build-a-bear to hide and when we were in
there we were like wait this is really
awesome like so we each got our own and
i named it franklin actually franklin is
in season two of high school musical um
in my bedroom if you go back you can see
he's he's in the background
does joshua play sports why don't you
tell him matt joshua basta does not play
sports not even a little so uh yeah
sports aren't my thing but uh i play
instruments so
does joshua bassett have tattoos
that's a no i think my mom would kill me
i really want to get the second star to
the right like on my thumb here just
because i love peter pan and i was peter
pan when i was 12 in a musical so i just
love like the sort of youthful reminder
to keep the youthful spirit alive in me
does joshua best like billy joel do i my
dad played billy joel all the time
growing up one of the first songs i ever
learned in the piano was piano man uh by
billy joel so yeah how many times do you
think you played piano man on set way
too many times many times way too many
many many times remember that one day
when uh the dp yelled at me they were
like how long is it going to take to get
this shot set up and he's like a hell of
a lot faster if you stop playing that
again
i was like
how old was joshua bassett oh
in grey's anatomy
i was 17. it was right after i booked
high school musical so i remember going
into that audition and being like i mean
i'm about to go shoot this show so
whatever happens happens and i feel like
because i felt less pressure the
audition went that much better but uh
yeah i think i was 17. oh what
episode episode is matt cornett
in bella and the
bulldogs in a few episodes i couldn't
tell you the episode numbers but i know
mostly season two there's actually one
really fun episode where we're in like
the wild wild west it was the first time
i got to wear like a cowboy hat and like
overalls and everything for for a show
and on a show on a show yeah
i grew up in arkansas definitely
yeah no that was that was my my everyday
actually there are so many baby pictures
of me and overalls and it's
terrifying where did matt cornett
go to high school technically i didn't
go anywhere for high school i did public
school uh in arkansas through eighth
grade and then started online school in
high school and it was horrible and i
hated it because i didn't get like the
high school experience although i did
get that through my brother and sister
and there was a part of me that was like
i just want the high school experience
but i feel like i've had it no yeah
musical music i think you're doing all
right does matt cornett
sing yeah yes yes i sing i think i don't
however know uh my vocal range but i i
do sing does matt cornett
have siblings i have an older brother
and older sister so i'm the baby my
brother and i are like like best best
friends i go to him for a lot of advice
so he's he's still still going to be
that older brother figure even when he's
60 and i'm
however old i am when he's 60. is it
okay if i break this yeah
oh all right that's also my my hair
stuff anyway
paper cut for the ages okay two does
jason earls
actually no karate
i know television karate so like if i
want to hurt myself i can do karate the
thing i'm better at actually is
brazilian jiu jitsu i did that while we
were doing kicking it and i'm a big fan
of that it's a little bit easier on the
body than
getting punched and kicked in karate are
jason earls oh are and miley cyrus
related
i will say that even though i'm not
genetically related to the cyruses billy
ray like almost immediately adopted me
as an official cyrus and was calling me
jason race iris they had a spare room
made up for me in their house so if i
didn't want to drive back and forth i
would crash at their place they were
exceptionally wonderful and gracious so
i do consider miley to be like family
and really like a little sister but we
do not share
any genetics
at all is jason earls
hawkeye
[Laughter]
why doesn't jason earls age
he does don't worry i do no i look a lot
older than i used to but i feel like
being in that environment where you're
being creative and you're being young
and youthful and silly and it it
actually does sort of manifest itself
and how you like age and how like the
energy that you put out there so i think
i don't age partially because i just
refuse to grow up jason earl's birth
chart i'm a taurus and if there ever was
a taurus i'm a tourist i'm super loyal
like ride or die till the end but if you
me over
i carry like serious grudges so i'm i am
i am very much a tourist
thank you so much for tuning in and that
concludes our wired auto complete
interview